and finally awesome event at parkdale  community center today las vegas ace's  chief business development officer and  women's basketball legend jennifer azee  teamed up with a non-profit group shoes  that fit this organization delivered 200  pairs of athletic shoes to local kids  and gave them a hoops camp we all know  how important basketball shoes are to  the experience they are both essential  and expressive and kids are getting a  jump on the game that's really we were  actually just talking about shoes  earlier i mean it was just it's so  important right and  keep everybody healthy too right keep  their legs strong probably make a little  better player exactly all right we'll  see you at 11 tonight